whether they openly declare themselves
as Communists fascists Nazis socialists
populists nationalists or globalists in
the end there are no substantive
differences that is Javier Malay the new
Argentinian president who's been branded
by the media as a right-wing Trump style
politician but in reality Malay is
critical of the far right and the left
not only called out socialism in his
speech at the world economic Forum he
also bashed nationalism and fascism now
in Argentina Decades of socialist rule
have destroyed the economy impoverished
the people and caused runaway inflation
Malay is now attempting to restore
fiscal sanity which will hurt in the
short term but hopefully get his country
back on the road to Prosperity it
happens to be leftists who are
responsible for the problems in
Argentina that doesn't mean Malay is
rightwing just because he wants to
reverse their failed policies socialism
and nationalism are both failed ideas
because they Empower governments to
violate the rights of individuals